alors que le cinéma vox fermé ses portes
en 2019 et que le rideau rouge symbole
du lieu devait finir à la déchetterie
loudenne est là et si tu y ailles qui
forment les enchanteuses ont décidé de
se lancer dans le projet de le
revaloriser ce velours rouge si
représentatif pour les rambolitains
trouvent une seconde vie avec ses
accessoires de mode c'est une très
grande chance pour nous puisqu'on a vu
tout à fait par hasard par le biais de
facebook que
cinéma dépouillé un petit peu de tout
son matériel on s'est posé la question
se disant mais quand il fait du rideau
rouge et donc on a contacté le monsieur
sur la page facebook qui qui s'occupait
effectivement de vider un petit peu le
cinéma de son contenu on va dire et ce
monsieur nous a livré le rideau en fait
là dans trois jours il part à la
déchetterie puisque personne ne la
récupère et voilà on est arrivé à point
nommé pour récupérer ce rideau est bien
évidemment de là les idées ont commencé
à fuser après plus de deux ans de
travail ce défilé sous le thème du 7e
art marque le lancement de cette
collection pour les deux créatrices
elles ont présenté lors de ce défilé 22
pièces toutes composées de ce vélo la
base y avait 80 mètres carrés il y avait
un petit peu de perte parce qu'il ya des
morceaux qui ont été abîmés etc mais on
a récupéré 60 mètres carrés les anciens
propriétaires du cinéma à l'origine de
l'installation de ce rideau était
présent lors du défilé c'est très très
touchant très émouvant bien sûr ce que
c'est une très jolie idée on imaginait
bien évidemment pas que ce rideau se
transformerait en magnifique sac en en
oeuvre unique parce que c'est des
oeuvres c'est de la création poussés par
leur volonté d'éviter le gaspillage
chaque pièce est unique et faites sur
commande elles présenteront la deuxième
partie du défilé le dimanche 26
septembre lors des 24 tours de
rambouillet